in Hollywood were famous for honoring
those who possess special talents like
acting or directing or singing or
producing but there is one award in our
industry that shines the spotlight on
something more significant something
more meaningful the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award this year's recipient
of the Hersholt is Harry Belafonte
singer producer actor a man whose
talents have entertained millions of
people around the world he has succeeded
in music theater film and television and
he has demonstrated his genius and
brilliance and creativity in all of them
he became a global artist before the
term even existed singing Jamaican
American Jewish and Irish folk songs and
launching the career of South Africa's
Miriam Makeba he's won a Tony Award
Grammys and an Emmy and at the same time
he was doing all of that he has been a
warrior on the good side of the
battlefield of social justice a man
whose true passion for activism has
helped change the lives of tens of
millions of people for the better
Harry Belafonte fought side by side with
dr. Martin Luther King jr. for civil
rights
he helped finance the Freedom Rides in
1961 and the Student Nonviolent
committee Coordinating Committee during
the 1964 Freedom Summer he helped design
the strategies that culminated in the
civil rights legislation of the 1960s
and when dr. King was arrested in
Birmingham Harry Belafonte was a driving
force in ensuring that the Birmingham
movement continued to grow while dr.
King was incarcerated he bailed dr. King
out of City Jail led voter registration
drives at a time when doing that could
result in you being murdered and
he was a leader in the 1963 march on
Washington and that was just what Harry
was doing here at home overseas he
fought against apartheid and apartheid
fell and when he saw that those who
hunger for freedom in Africa had
brothers and sisters across that
continent who hungered for food and
nourishment he came up with the idea for
the we are the world benefit record and
now he's going into the inner cities of
America to help end the plague of gang
violence that affects so many young
people Harry is a voice of reason and
compassion he's a man who has never
wavered once in his lifetime commitment
to his fellow man and women there's a
great line in The Grapes of Wrath from
Henry Fonda's Tom Joad I'll be
everywhere wherever you can look
wherever there's a fight so hungry
people can eat I'll be there wherever
there's a cop beating up a guy I'll be
there I'll be there in the way the guys
yell when they're mad I'll be in the way
kids laugh when they're hungry and they
know suppers ready and when the people
are eating the stuff they raise and
living in the house as they build I'll
be there too Tom Joad was a a classic
but fictional American hero Harry is a
real-life flesh and blood hero a man
who's 87 years on this planet we call
home has been spent fighting injustice
and for human rights and human dignity
Harry's always been on the right side of
history but that has meant that
sometimes he's been on the wrong side of
popular opinion he's the ultimate
example of a great artist and a lifelong
social activist who somehow has done
both better than just about anyone in
either field it's an honor for all of us
to be in the same room with
and for me to present him with this
year's Jean Hersholt Award Humanitarian
Award I love you Harry